resident evil has had many faces and
even the lack of one
over its 25 years of existence i've seen
this franchise
transform mold and redefine itself over
and over and over again
being everything from a teeth grinding
horror madhouse to a co-op
over the top hollywood action romp to
most recently
an absolute thirst trap wow i've seen
the franchise take detours into
different
genres set pieces and concepts some more
successful than
others and everything the franchise has
attempted
accomplished and even failed at is in
resident evil village one way or another
from a genre defining breakthrough to
some of the more
debatable entries resident evil village
is the
most resident evil game of them all
let me break this down the foundation of
resident evil village lies on
well the actual village it's a sprawling
maze-like area with dead ends locked
doors and obtuse paths
but as the game progresses it connects
to the other areas unraveling new ones
to be discovered rewarding the player
with keys and items that compel them
to backtrack and re-explore it this was
a trope defined by the franchise's very
first entry back in 1996
and it was a revolution for horror games
and the first to define a genre
the survival horror genre it took
elements from adventure games with
exploration
backtracking and item-based puzzles and
then apply to survival to it
by giving the player very limited
resources and enemies that soaked up
that precious
precious ammunition it was a slow paced
slog through a maze-like environment of
narrow halls
forcing the player to make life or death
choices around every corner of the
confusingly designed
oswell spencer mansion this is a
characteristic that would come and go
through the franchise with backtracking
and puzzles being last seen most
prominently
in the fourth entry in the series code
veronica back in 2000.
it did make its grand return in resident
evil 7 but
even then the exploration was pale in
comparison to 1
2 and veronica that is until
resident evil village the village opens
and unravels similarly to the original
oswell mansion from one
and the raccoon city police department
from two or even more accurately
like code veronica's european gothic
palace and victorian mansion
especially considering its similar
aesthetic to lady dimitresk's castle
in resident evil village speaking of big
lady d let's talk about being chased
as you navigate the halls of
demotresque's castle she and her
daughters will stalk and follow you as
you desperately try to find
keys and items to unlock and open other
areas
this iconic and terrifying
characteristic comes straight from
resident evil 3
nemesis resident evil 3 threw a wrench
in the tropes that one and two had
created
trading off the slow pacing for urgency
and paranoia that big baddy nemesis
could bust through at any moment
a towering invincible foe that stalks
you constantly
ramping up the pressure when you least
expect it
like many ideas of the resident evil
franchise the mechanic of constantly
being pursued wouldn't make a return
until again resident evil 7 with jack
baker
but it wasn't fully mastered until
resident evil 2 remake with mr x
the resident evil 2 remake took jack
baker's stalking mechanic
and launched it to the nth degree with
mr x making him a towering silent goon
that slammed through
anything to get you mr x did make an
appearance in the og resident evil 2
during the b
scenario but not to the same degree as
nemesis and capcom
but at full force in the remake lady
demotress is the embodiment of
both jack baker and mr x a family woman
just looking after her own while also
being an intimidatingly huge individual
big i'm gonna [ __ ] you up real hard
energy
while you're traversing villages many
different environments there'll be
treasure to find
animals to hunt and this jolly old fella
to find solace in as you sell items
upgrade weapons and buy
new ones that you can organize in your
tetris-like inventory
all of this is thanks to resident evil
4. residual 4 ripped the franchise away
from its fixed camera angles expanded
your arsenal and turn the harrowing odds
against one zombie
up to 11 favoring overwhelming stress
over pure horror
a near copy of village's encounters with
a lichens
especially in its opening sequence when
you're overwhelmingly outnumbered and
have to barricade yourself into a house
four introduced the tetris-like
inventory case the treasure hunting
currency and a merchant to sell items
with most of these mechanics are
defining a four's identity
and interestingly never appear in the
franchise again
that is until now with village some of
four's influences on village may not be
as apparent
as others however probably the most
notorious area
in village is house beneviento which not
only features an adorable baby but
these terrifying ghost dolls which
aren't
entirely new to the franchise while 4
was in development it had gone through
several different prototypes until
coming to what it is today
one internal version of the game was
known as the hallucination version in
this prototype build there was a room
known simply as
the doll room where leon kennedy would
fight against these pesky
19th century porcelain dolls while this
didn't end up making the cut for
resident evil 4 it was revived and
cemented in village
leaning full force into the supernatural
elements that resident evil
only toyed with behind the curtains and
it gets to be a little nice wink and nod
to us resident evil nerds who caught it
and with no reasonable transition let's
talk about chris redfield
an overarching plot device in resident
evil village is chris who swoops into
the opening moments of the game killing
ethan's wife and kidnapping his baby
chris is among the longest standing
characters in the franchise first
appearing in resident evil 1 alongside
jill valentine
but the game to have the most defining
impact on his character shaping him into
the bulky military head that he is now
is resident evil 5. taking him from the
soft face
boy from resident evil 1 and code
veronica and establishing his military
attitude
and muscles mechanically village didn't
really take that much from the co-op
focused five
aside from carrying the weight of
redfield's pecs but when resident evil 6
rolled around
it had completely launched the franchise
into full-blown hollywood antics with
over-the-top
action and a sprawling cast of
characters that make even a soap opera
jealous
village captures six essence at its
finest near the closing hours
when we step into the shoes of chris
tricep redfield and go
buck wild on waves of likens all call of
duty style
all of which comes to a close with a
mushroom cloud
while resident evil 6 is notoriously
divisive among fans for being a
full-on hollywood action game it seems
that village couldn't help itself from
going
a little off the rails once again but
hey at least it didn't have a zombie
t-rex
monster thing right
obviously resident evil village carried
a lot over from its predecessor resident
evil 7.
while seven softly returned to its
exploration and backtracking roots
its biggest contribution to the
franchise was its change to a
first-person perspective
resident evil 7 was the first true
reimagining the franchise
had seen in a decade since resident evil
4 but this time around making it first
person
leaning all in on horror and lightly
attempting to revisit the franchise's
dna with an
emphasis on tight spaces exploration and
arbitrary locked doors
this is something that village doubles
down on more interesting is how the game
is structured
showcasing resident evil 7's antagonists
as a family
front and center with each foe having
their own distinct area to explore and
maneuver through
a prominent trait carried over into
village's narrative structure when being
introduced to
the four lords resident evil 7 felt like
an attempt to reposition the franchise
with a new generation and revisit old
concepts in a way
that was more palatable with modern
gaming trends
it would have been risky for capcom to
put new players against a sprawling
intricate mansion filled with puzzles
and backtracking
tropes that hadn't been seen in
mainstream aaa games for
decades at this point but after 7's
success those very elements of
backtracking item searching
and exploration came back full force in
resident evil 2 remake
resident evil 2 remake was a
no-holds-barred representation of what
classic resident evil exploration and
inventory management was but built
into the modern age and now making a
grander
more expansive return in village lastly
we need to talk about resident evil lore
because village
is just bursting at the seams with it in
the final
hours of the game it is revealed that
the main villain mother miranda's
existence
recontextualizes the backstory of the
entire franchise but no other game has
made a similar contribution
other than code veronica one that i
believe helped define resident evil's
absurd and complicated lore that we know
oh so well today resident evil has grown
to have a soap opera-like backstory that
spans hundreds of years
involving nazi-like virologists cloning
australian families and bio-organic
terrorism
and veronica was the first to take it
all and put it front
and center introducing rather theatrical
and
eccentric villains opening the gates
beyond just oswell spencer's madness and
introducing edward
ashford a character like spencer fixated
on cloning and biochemical shenanigans
basically code veronica's ashford family
walked so resin before salazar could run
and villages for lords could soar and
in many ways village's four lords while
still an iteration on seven's baker
family
feels closely akin in their theatrics
and over-the-top personas to
code veronica's ashford family
especially in the end of village when we
learn mother miranda's impact on the
entire franchise's lore
which is a lot to impact this is similar
to the impact the ashford family had on
resident evil's lore that interlaced
alongside oswell spencer
veronica had the most deepening effect
on the game's lore
at that time just as village has now
causing a ripple effect
for what's to come the future of the
franchise
now up to this point with each new
installment resin evil has introduced a
new idea some of which were iterated on
for sequels to come
while others were left behind as the
genre shaped and molded
resident evil village on the other hand
has left none of those ideas
behind more than any resident evil
before it village does the most
to embody everything the franchise has
been
up to this point village is a
culmination of all of them
every single element wrapped up and
stapled together
whether it works well that's up to you
to decide but
unabashedly and of course as a resident
evil apologist at times
i love it and while it does feel like a
frankenstein's monster
it is an encapsulation of the
franchise's 25
years and for that reason alone it makes
village one of the most special resident
evil games
today and it does a lot to push the
franchise forward
while doubling down on its past
[Music]
[Music]
you